[Music]  so  [Music]  hey everybody i'm katie a tasty producer  bringing you some tips on this recipe so  my first tip is if you like mint but you  don't love mint you can pull back on the  mint extract a little bit and instead of  doing a half a teaspoon try a quarter  teaspoon my second tip is when putting  the cookies in the bowl it can seem kind  of intimidating so you start with one in  the middle you'll do six around it very  close and then you'll just kind of fill  in the gaps from there and if you know  what whatever you do it's gonna be  perfect even if it's not a perfectly  geometric cookie bowl for my final tip i  used a box brownie mix for this recipe  but you can totally make brownies from  scratch for this and it will probably  taste even more delicious i hope that  you guys like this recipe and leave in  the comments if you'd made it take  pictures we'd love to see it  talk to you guys later  [Music]  you